The is JavaScript.
Down here you see more than a dozen classes
that all have had plenty of security issues.
This is the correct answer.
One may wonder why is it that issues end up in a small number of places
and that such large parts of the code remain without any issues.
For JavaScript this is pretty clear.
This piece holds the JavaScript interpreter,
which interacts through many, many interfaces with the system.
All of these are possible attack vectors.
It's no surprise that JavaScript holds these many security issues.
Plus an interpreter is notoriously hard to get right.
HTML layout may come as a surprise.
After all, this is just the rearranging of appropriate user interface elements on the screen.
Why would there be security issues related to that?
The reason is cross-site scripting.
As soon as you layout multiple sources on one page,
it may be that one sources tries to access elements of the other source,
using your screen as a tunnel.
These issues are right here within HTML layout.
The document object model also allows accessing and manipulating individual elements.
This again is an open door for security issues
as well as for content base. I don't really know.